rome wasn't built in a day
we all know that everyone's hears that
but rome also didn't fall apart
overnight either it took hundreds of
years for Rome to reach its peak but it
also took time hundreds of years for
Rome to decay and fall apart and that is
representative of life because you don't
achieve worthwhile goals quickly or
easily they take time they take struggle
they take relentless pursuit day in and
day out that's what it takes but also
things don't usually fall apart quickly
either and at least at first it's it's a
slow process a little slip here little
setback over there a little wearing down
of discipline and will over time
[Music]
that's the thing success and failure are
generally slow processes either slowly
building things up or gradually tearing
them down
and that's why I say you've got to pay
attention you have to watch you have to
watch every single second because those
seconds they turn into minutes then
minutes turn into hours and hours turn
into days and days turn in to years and
so that second that just went by that
counted and so did that second and so
did that one and in those precious
seconds you're either building or you're
decaying you were either gaining ground
or you were losing ground
in that second
and in every second
[Music]
every second counts so make every second
count
[Music]
I'd like you to fast-forward to 70 80 90
years old right fast forward in your
mind to that age 70 80 90 100 110 if
you're really optimistic whichever one
it is and I'd like you to write down
what will be the things that you'll
regret that you didn't do
imagine you're that age ask yourself the
question what will I regret that I
didn't do know what you did do but what
you didn't do
write it down make a long list right now
get a pen and paper out and write it
down don't do on your phone don't do on
your laptop
I actually get a pen and paper and write
down your answers what will be the
things that you regret that you didn't
do right really think about it would it
be you know learning a new language will
it be moving home will it be telling
someone you love them what will it be
what would it be
write it down right now now the
incredible thing about this question is
that you're using the future to empower
the past whatever answer you have in
that question whatever your answer is
you can do it right now today starting
today because you're not that age and if
you're even if you're 64 and you're
tuning in 70 80 90 you're still there
right it's still possible you can start
doing that right now it's empowering the
present with the future there is nothing
stopping you from making it happen right
now
you don't have to feel that way when
you're 70 you don't have to feel that
way when you're 80 you never ever have
to feel that way if you start doing it
right now and you can do it right now
even if it feels impossible you can stop
working on it right now you can start
trying right now you can start making
plans right now because you're not there
yet and this is where you start this is
where you start making it happen it's
all in the now
you weren't born into a rich family
you're the wrong skin tone you're this
you're that I get it but just we got
yeah we got to get back you won the
lotto you want it you've got to get back
do something with it especially now
your grandparents didn't have this the
internet is crazy
it just is it just is and so why do you
think everybody's getting out in now
because three old white guys don't
control the media anymore do you think
that's happening here this is the
greatest era ever for anybody the market
the platform is the Internet this is
unbelievable unprecedented times we will
look back at this 200 years from now
like these that a good opportunity you
know somebody bought the land that we're
on right now for $1 at one point that's
what's happening with us on the internet
the attention of the end consumer is
cheap right now you can grab it around
whatever you want to be about and it
doesn't cost you anything other than
your time and so many of you are
complaining but then are too fancy to
put in the 15 hours a day to get it I
got no respect for that I got no respect
for anybody who complains and isn't
putting in the work raise your standard
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's something serene if you want
to learn how to free yourself from your
fears I highly recommend the video we
made on how to conquer fear the link is
right next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you there I think everybody has
fear all wrong the only way to deal with
fear that I found in my life is a couple
ways